welcome to the to the show on Monday
this marks I think according to my
SmartWatch our seventh year in
quarantine even my watch is starting to
drink yeah it's really getting sad look
I don't want to complain or anything
because I know all of us are struggling
to get through this and I'm just lucky
to be here lucky to be doing these shows
and lucky to have friends out there I
want to show you something this is a
shirt that got sent to me in the mail I
just opened it up check it out it's from
my hometown look at it
Boston Boston look at that look at that
nice shirt and that's the that's the
Bunker Hill bridge I got it from a
company I'm not getting paid for this I
mean I am I got a shirt out of it a
company called Sully sent me this shirt
and I put it on and I think they were
thinking hey Conan's doing his shows
we're gonna send him a shirt from Boston
and it's gonna make him think a Boston
and his childhood in Boston and feel
good again here's the problem people at
Sully's this shirt that bridge was put
up in 2003 I left Boston in 1985 with
just a stick with a little bundle on the
back the point is this doesn't evoke my
childhood at all this is a new bridge
this to me just looks like a penis
that's being held up with wire that's
what it looks like and you guys it's
always are like this will make come and
feel good no it doesn't this doesn't it
all remind me of my childhood I never
saw this bridge growing up you want to
remind me of my childhood make a shirt
that shows my father knocking a hot dog
out of my hand cuz Jim Rice dropped a
fly ball okay I'm sorry Sully's you seem
like a nice company thanks for the shirt
very phallic but that's not my childhood
all right well I'm gonna stop bitching
because I got a job to do here and first
of all let me tell you a lot of people
are wondering what's going on in
Hollywood people want the Hollywood
gossip
okay the hot Goss I call it so
I'm making it my job I created a special
segment on our quarantine shows called
the Hollywood buzz with our special
correspondent Mario Lopez yes very
excited about this we tried it last week
Mario didn't have much for us then but
he's had a whole week so let's go now to
Mario Lopez and the Hollywood buzz
hey Mario what's going on in Hollywood
still nothing Conan
you